the first question comes from demanding
and it's how to stay motivated my focus
project and pull off of things last time
we talked about you know what's the
anger what do you visualize the success
you know what it what is that mountain
you want to climb and when you're on a
long project especially you need to keep
focused on that and then tan and Evans
point is I think you need kind of
routine structure and rhythm and that
cadence of momentum towards their kind
of climbing the mountain and put the
flag on the top of the mountain but
you've got to keep that in mind you've
got to visualize that because some days
about dates and unless you remember the
mission you're on then you can connect
drift and and and ultimately just Lewis
yo Joe and we don't want that happen
yeah I think to add to that it can be
really hard to stay motivated where it's
a zero one scenario where like it's hard
to tell if you're making progress in
getting momentum having success where
you're only there's only one success
criteria and it's so long before you get
there I think what helps is if you have
milestones and you bring it down and any
long project anything I might take you
five years ago to accomplish and that
can be super demotivating if you have no
milestones hard to stay on that track
and so I would encourage you to break it
down into smaller milestone so what can
I do this year this quarter this month
this week that if I accomplish these
things I'll feel good about myself I
feel like this thing is moving we're
making progress and that it'll get you
motivated they're going to get back on
your horse and go do it again and it's
important sometimes it's kind of
entrepreneurs we forget this when you
hit those milestones celebrate them yeah
it's just literally even if it's just
sent to the team farmer six people in
your business say well done guys just go
and have a beer down the bar we made it
we made the first master we made the
fifteenth milestone we should really
congratulate ourselves but then you know
that's all behind us and it's the next
milestone we've got to focus on yeah
it's so easy just to get you'll be happy
to have the goal and move on and try to
find the next one but we just crossed
100 thousands of survivors on the
channel uh last week last village yeah
thank you right until made a video like
it's a hundred thousand yeah subscriber
video everybody was involved thinking
it's
the audience was involved and I I love
the point you gotta celebrate your wins
as entrepreneurs we're so focused on our
business sometimes we forget to
celebrate the little things that we've
done that have moved our company for you
a little thing ever not talked about
this is hanh industry because sometimes
as an entrepreneur it's about for the
next meal on the table looking after
your kids looking at your family
building a business keeping the customer
but sometimes it's kind of good to
imagine it's much a much bigger story
you're creating history you're making a
difference you're making a difference
for you your family your customers
you've got in the community and when you
think alike that you know I use phrases
like you could be sitting at the
ringside seat of history where you're
making something really special and
sustainable and it's important to hang
on to that because there you know you're
following a noble cause you're following
your dreams you're following what you're
passionate about and when you remember
that then that kind of allows you not
only to see the big project cbn go break
it down into milestones but also
celebrate and just imagine one day
someone's going to be writing books on
you and making movies about sitting at
the ring side of history I like I'm
writing that one down I like that